earlier this week Tim Sweeney one of the
co-founder one of the founders of Epic
Games came out to criticize Microsoft
you wrote like a lengthy feature talking
about the the Microsoft Windows platform
it's this new sort of an API a software
development tool they're using to allow
developers to make games for all windows
devices with just one set of code yeah
ports it automatically Tim Sweeney's
concern is like okay what that's doing
because Microsoft is known for phasing
out support for stuff Microsoft takes
this approach phases out the old sort of
Wild West win32 application system where
people could just make anything for any
version of Windows you could download
from the website and play it if they get
rid of that and it's just this uwp this
United Windows platform developers and
gamers are going to be sort of taken out
of the equation they're gonna have to go
through Microsoft for everything so ty I
know that you kind of understand a
little bit more about this yeah it's I
don't know if we I he makes some
interesting points and I understand that
coming from his you know side why he's a
little scared right now and why he he's
concerned but I don't I don't I don't
necessarily know I think there's always
going to be that side load option in
Windows 10 I'm almost positive that you
can set a security parameter that says i
can install anything you can do that
right now yes so but what happened with
Windows 8 is Microsoft eventually made
that part of only the Enterprise Edition
got it one guys so there is a chance
maybe that's why I'm concerned yeah yeah
I mean if this is tough right I can see
both sides of the argument here I think
windows I think Microsoft smart I mean
they're they're at the stage now where I
believe like if you look at other
operating systems you know like Mac
they're growing their install base is
growing windows are shrinking you know
it's it's not as it means still the
dominant force right you know especially
with gaming you know but in I guess an
enterprise but for the most part they
are losing numbers and they need to the
PC like is a like if you ask my parents
and my grandmother it's a damn mess and
it drives them nuts color up let's do
another one said we should write my 91
year old grandma hates but no it's
interesting because I mean you set
yourself with the win32 API like it
it's been very open yes but the problem
is like applications can you know they
might request access from other
applications it might be digging into
your hard drive like at no point when
you I just fill at no point when you
change your OS like should things just
break right and not work or when you
install a program it causes another
program to break and work I mean this is
why things like xbox one ps4 the ayah
phone I iPads anything any closed
ecosystem is popular because it's made
for ninety percent of the people ninety
percent of the time right but if you
look at the sort of control Microsoft is
trying to have over everything up that
puts like it's alarming well I mean cuz
developers now can put out any app they
want right on game shows you can
download it install it through this this
uwp Microsoft has to approve they do
everything right and we've seen how that
works on the Apple App Store where
certain things get denied for sometimes
just like cold systemic reasons like
it's sort of putting at least this is my
opinion like it's putting these sort of
like locking key on things that are
forever it's been open and you know
people have to be smart enough to
navigate open waters mm-hmm but I'm not
sure they can think about it this way
this is a whole other platform that
people have to consider on PC like we've
already got seen which everyone loves
yes and you've got you play and you've
got origin is origin still a thing right
origin is still think they try to like
rebrand it the thing is we don't know we
don't need a whole other one well then
that's the appeal of a pc right exactly
is well using source is it that's why i
have it ok i mean i'm talking like to
the average person though like I think
to us you i agree with you guys one
hundred percent i think we want to get
like some there was a i think in
Sweeney's article there was like
something talked about how like there's
like this element of like danger and
excitement that you feel when you have a
pc and like it just don't open that
something just works right and you're
just like dad that worked i can't
believe i got that to work you know i
mean and part of the reason why a lot of
the developers are worried is because
like you look at like rise of the Tomb
Raider on Windows 10 that was a mess
like that that game didn't even let you
run full screen like it was a windowed
full screen didn't take full advantage
of the video card there was some other
weird like SLI problems with that game
but you know you download on steam it
works perfectly right so I get all that
but the same time is like you know how
big is like the audience like us that
uses pcs the game and do a
this other weird [ __ ] like how big are
we compared to the general enterprise
type audience creative audience that
just wants a goddamn computer to work
properly right but you I think it was
you that was telling me that your
computer wanted to update to Windows 10
that pissed me off and you had left auto
update on to be fair yeah the problem is
if not really piss me off if Microsoft
does this right like again no gears of
war ultimate edition yeah yeah it was
only available on Windows 10 with
directx 12 which presented a bunch of
problems for people yeah again I'm I'm
not defend I'm not like defending or
supporting the decision I'm just I can
understand why they're doing it yeah
that's what I'm coming from like I agree
yeah made me really mad when I like when
windows tim was about to install
automatically and i was like what the
hell and then by the way also downloaded
the damn thing to my computer and a
hidden drive that i couldn't delete and
then when i did delete it it reinstalled
it again or downloaded again so yeah
there's some shady [ __ ] going on there
and it made me mad but the thing is is
like how off like they're pushing so
aggressively with this right they want
everyone to adopt Windows 10 and they're
going to force you to do it you know
like there I feel like they're they're
kind of taking some cues from Apple but
they're just getting a lot more [ __ ] for
it and it's it's it's interesting is
there concern that they'll be taking a
cut from they are taking it is they are
alike what's that yeah it's the same
thirty seventy percent okay amazing
thing yeah i mean i think so i don't
know for sure i'm almost positive as
thirty percent use from I i say this
with absolutely no conviction whatsoever
but i think it's i think their store
they are taking a cut yeah yeah it would
make sense that they would but they are
allowing you to download uwp certified
applications from other sources right
like phil spencer said that like they
are allowing you to do that so it's i
understand why everyone's kind of
freaking out I just don't I just think
the jury's still out I don't think
people should just freaked out for no
apparent reason yet without listening to
all the facts and hearing what's going
on because I would love to make the pc
gaming experience better right like just
smoother and I mean I we do all of our
work in pc like with you know with Adobe
Creative Cloud and like all these other
applications that we use you know like I
I need them to work and when they don't
work and [ __ ] just breaks it is very
frustrating well it's especially with
Adobe I mean like that almost presents
its own issue because in the past you
could just have those apps
have to worry about connecting to the
cloud to like yeah make sure your
license was good oh yeah now it's all
the time I mean it's a sign of things
changing for the worse yeah it's like a
nightmare now unlike something updates
an adobe creative cloud and then like
half your [ __ ] doesn't work so I mean it
would be great to have some sort of
uniformity there but the same time I
understand why you know some gamers are
you know antsy get it is this a concern
I mean I know gear so gears is obviously
a microsoft exclusive so is that just
the main concern is that like all
exclusive say halo down the road wants
to make its way to PC it it will have to
go through the system is basically what
the idea is also the idea is that if
Microsoft takes away the ability to
sideload apps into uwp or the ability to
release downloadable exe files based on
the old win32 method then everyone will
have to go through uwp analyst constr
everyone they might not have to sell it
through that store they won't have to do
that at least not okay they won't have
to do right now but that's the concern
right that's where it's all coming from
and so if they have to do that sure they
could still sell the game through steam
but they would have to conform to the
tools and the policies that are that I
hearing in being part of UW and that may
not be such a horrible thing if you sell
through a third party store but then at
least you have that uwp certification it
says hey this app is just going to
install it's not going to go fishing
through your [ __ ] it's not gonna look
for anything else it's not going to
install anything nefarious that's gonna
screw up something else it's legit
because we you know certain we started
yeah and that part actually I like i
might be getting crucified by a bunch of
a game i'm sure you are yeah but I mean
I like that part of it but at the same
time I to understand like you know it's
also a giant corporation they want to
make money and I get all that so I get
the concerns I just think that the
jury's still out all right well are you
guys worried about the future of Windows
gaming why do you love gaming on PC in
the first place I know for me was always
downloading those incredibly modern norm
going with us never mind pc gaming the
Wild West might be I know I was gonna
get inappropriate
you